x squared plus one on top of my favorite
credit okay
now you can see before you put pen to
paper I've got all my previous working
on the board still right there is a
significant problem with using this for
this
what's the significant problem okay so
the fact that I have the same degree on
the numeric neridah for starters that
that looks at that just looks different
right from from this question that looks
different
why does that cause me problems that
like if for instance if for instance I'd
said I'd said that and changed it right
it would still work so just changing the
power is not a problem it's a specific
problem here ready
very good okay so the specific reason
why having the degrees match is a
problem with this approach is that when
you get to what when you get to here
right I've got an X to the one term I've
got X to the zero term
I've got no x squared term and you never
will buy this particular pair of
fractions so then you think what what
what what could I do like this this
simplified method this is right where
you should generated when I said ah
let's just see if this works right is
insufficient to deal with two could be
the public is so what can I do how can I
bring an X gonna do kind of what you're
suggesting but in Reverse so what ref is
suggesting is or if the x squared plus
one is a problem don't you in the x
squared plus one don't do with the x
squared at all in fact deal with it as
like the opposite of that poem you try
and get the rest of it okay maybe that's
a bit unclear to you it certainly wants
to me when it first got explained to me
that way I was like what and then I saw
a question I'm gonna explain a little
bit differently it's you do you wanna
okay so another suggestion is well the
reason why you're not getting any any x
squared terms out of here is because of
you guys
they're just constants right so when you
move this next line of course you are
not going to get any expert terms in
there because X never gets multiplied by
X again so an alternative would be to
say well let's stick an X in there in
one of these right there's a problem
with that though we will end up doing
things like that later on when we have a
look at things that can't simply be
factorized down into linear factors at
least not many are real factors but the
problem with it is like the shortcoming
with it is when you have a look at this
right side look I came from this pan if
I changed this question and made it like
2 X plus 3 it's just as an example okay
how do I know at this point in the
question without any prior knowledge how
do I know which of these ones is going
to have the closer turn on right and
which one is going to have the X term on
if I say well you don't know you just
have to assume it could be either of
them then you will end up with something
like this now can anyone tell me why
this would give us problems talking the
fact that looks gross I have 4 unknowns
4 unknowns and how many equations are
you going to get out of them to soul no
enough not actually going to get enough
there's there's too many options it's a
different number conference actually
yeah
we could do long division I'm going to
show you a way which is going to get
around that and end up with the same
result before I show you my my and your
give one more suggestion is it possible
to be you can't go into complex numbers
but boy I'm going to try not to because
as we know call these coefficients they
drastically make something much more
complicated which is why they're in
Cumberland right Jesse do you want to
give one plus you can okay all right all
right so so so this sounds ridiculous
sounds ridiculous but I'm going to come
back to this guy here now we assume
because what I'm searching for is a way
to still have this should preserve the
simplicity of the method not going to
this disaster right but I need to bring
in expert term I will tell you the
quickest way to do it you can see I
obviously need this pair of fractions
yes so I'm gonna begin by blindness so
I've got some X plus two some three
these two by themselves no x squared
terms so the simplest way to do this is
to add one you're like what what you saw
this does that bring to the question I
want to point out two things no more I
can do this I can do this
I I don't know what a and B are right
they can be anything I could have made
this two or three or four or five I want
to remember when I gave you that
original quartet right and I said can
you put this in X square plus K X as a
quadratic in that I didn't have to I
could have made it expand minus K X or x
squared minus whatever you can reshape
it as any kind of like you can use
there's an infinite number of polynomial
identities out there you use whichever
is simplest and most convenient for you
this is pretty simple the way I'm going
to do it is the messy
which come in this way is that one
degree that one is simply x squared plus
5x plus 6 on x squared plus 5x plus 6
here that I wanted an expensive right
there he is right adding 1 the reason
why it's useful is well I just need to
add some kind of constant term really
because if I have a constant term that
will enable me to get a quadratic
something of the same degree up on the
numerator okay
I could add 2 or 3 or 50 I suppose but
it would just make the mass of a walk
with one is the simplest one I can
choose
he's the billion thing I don't watch
right if I have these original pair of
partial fractions hanging out on the
same here this is where I'm gonna now go
to wraps explanation right this guy here
is in fact more than what I've got here
so in order to get from here to here
I've got to take away some stuff right
in fact the difference between this and
this is it looks like it's 5 X plus 5 on
this do you agree with that that is the
discrepancy between this fraction here
and where I came from
ok so therefore what these guys are
going to do is they're not going to add
together to become the original they are
going to add together to become the
difference that right so this a by
Oliver bar is going to turn into this
and that's okay there are being annexed
to the one term and there will be a
constant term so I'm gonna be okay with
this let's watch it on forward okay what
I'm gonna do is in exactly the same way
I'm going to
I'm going to say well that's world ease
all together into one gigantic faction
so that I can not worry about the
denominator and just compare the
numerators
okay so I'll do that so that's going to
give me an expert plus 5x plus 6 on the
top because it's already in the right
denominator this a is going to turn into
a X plus 3 do you agree that and the B
will turn into B X plus 2 and it's all
over just now I'm going to do the same
thing I did here on this bottom line I'm
going to get all the x squared terms
only one of them all the X terms and all
the constant terms I'm going to gather
them together to make the comparison of
coefficients straightforward so it looks
to me like well x squared terms already
out the front only X terms do you see
yeah I see this guy and this guy and
this guy right so there are three of
them so I'm gonna write the x squared at
the front then I'm gonna write it as the
gives a 5 plus a plus B that's how many
X's there are and in the same way the
constants let's just label them for the
sake of completeness constant there
there's gonna be three a here and
there's going to be there do you agree
that once you've expanded all out so
again to indicate that they're actually
one unit I'm gonna write them in markets
6 plus
okay now I'm not even going to go ahead
and do the working because at this point
I have simply reduced that problem which
is more complex into this problem which
is exactly the same thing we did before
five plus a plus B look at the original
fraction what's the coefficient of x
individual fraction zero no X terms
right so five plus a plus B will be zero
what are this six plus three plus two B
that's going to match up to build y -
all right yeah yeah okay so again it
looks a bit more awkward because you've
got more like numbers in there not
because you have a course on the right
hand side it all just comes out to watch
it'll look exactly like this can you go
ahead and do that equation 1/5 plus a
plus B equals zero equation - 6 plus 3 n
plus 2 B equals 1
by comparison coefficients keep go ahead
and do that okay it's down to me and
then I will finish writing this up okay
so I mean because the numbers are quite
simple you might be there excuse me
so what I've got now is a and B I
suppose I mean what did you do what was
your first else okay you I think
multiplying I mean you generally she's
the smallest number you can clearly you
can model number three if you want why
would you so you double this and then
you subtract I guess you'd subtract this
from this because then you'll just have
a by itself positive as one okay which
of course gives you a as being equal to
five yeah and then you're gonna get 10
okay so when you bring that down into
our original identity or the one we
introduced start you've got one you've
got the five this is a negative so I'm
gonna okay if you wanted to clarify what
ran for saying before the difference
thing you could I suppose buy it in this
way that it's one and then you're taking
away these guys right go take you away I
just watch the signs there I guess I'm
at it like this
what I'm saying here is that that part
pair of partial fractions what it would
turn into is this sum of five x plus
five that go into completing the whole
thing so therefore I have to take them
away because they're not really there I
got it actually wanted okay but I think
this is fine this is just the clarify
that's actually okay any questions on
that we will get to those so I'm gonna
probably not either in this lesson
because I want to sort of to be what
we're going to do for us I have some
material that I'm gonna continue I'm
just going to pause before I let you go
for it and just notice again like the
great thing about this is now if I gave
you that right like this is again the
same kind of question were you like why
why do you do this to me but if you know
how to do this the question becomes
trivial becomes a very very simple thing
to do in fact this is kind of our bridge
we're not doing it now it's kind of a
bridge from this topic polynomials into
higher integration extension to what
happens is extension to students is this
sort of circle of functions that you
know how to integrate it widens somewhat
dramatically